it's great to be joined today by luke
vargas who is united nations bureau
chief for talk media news he has joined
us over the years from all over the
world and today we are talking about
Donald Trump and climate change the
one-year anniversary of the Paris
climate agreement is today which has
been a source source of much discussion
from Donald Trump do we even have a
sense now Luke of exactly where Trump
stands on climate change of course the
ranging from leading a climate-science
denier to had the EPA and suggesting
that climate change is a hoax created by
the Chinese to saying that hey he
believes in science and he'll listen to
people Ivanka Trump even meeting with Al
Gore where does Trump stand on this
right now we honestly don't know where
he stands he's been all over the place
for instance in 2009 he signed this open
letter to President Obama which ran in
the New York Times other people it's
called the business leaders for
environmental change letters Ben and
Jerry signed it the CEO of seventh
generation that fancy paper company that
sells at Whole Foods this is not the
crowd that Donald Trump rolls with now
and both he his sons and ivanka I'll
sign this letter which among other
things called for President Obama in
2009 to go to those Copenhagen climate
talks that Hillary Clinton talked about
so much in the primary and to deliver
robust emissions targets binding ones
that was a bit beyond what the Paris
agreement now does this is a big call
from him the letter went on to say if we
fail to act now it is a scientifically
irrefutable that there will be
catastrophic and irreversible
consequences for humanity and our planet
this is so far away from what Donald
Trump is saying now and much in the way
that he was sort of running to the left
of the American political establishment
on issues in the past like health care
at a time when Democrats would never
talk about single-payer it seemed like
Donald Trump just six years ago was
running to the left of the American
mainstream on climate change as well so
suffice it to say this guy is change
things around he is not only appointing
people to the cabinet who are
detrimental to the cause of climate
change action but saying things which
are also very unproductive and on top of
that threatening to remove the United
States from the Paris agreement so
across the board
Donald Trump has gone through a
tremendous reversal of positions um and
even just a few hours ago telling Fox
News that he really questions the
science behind climate change this is a
360 turn for Donald Trump 180 turn I'm
sure you mean 360 would get him right
back in the sale a source or yet uh so
we could he could end up there of course
protractors aside for a second though uh
I want to get into in a second the
specifics of what Trump could do with
regard to the Paris agreements but
before we do that generally every time
we hear about a trump pick for cabinet
or advisor or whatever one of the main
questions is okay here's what they
believe but how much could they
unilaterally do when it comes to actual
federal government actions what's the
worst case for actual climate policy the
worst case scenario looks to be
something close to what we have right
now which is that you have dangerous
appointees and very unhelpful public
statements on the appointee front we're
talking about putting someone to chair
the EPA who wants to diminish the power
of governmental regulations on a mission
someone in the body of Oklahoma Attorney
General Scott Pruitt someone at the
State Department who's not going to use
that office to go around the world like
Hillary Clinton or John Kerry didn't
promote multilateral action on climate
change but someone like CEO Rex
Tillerman a possible Secretary of State
nominee who will try to resurrect the
power of the fossil fuel industry and
squeeze whatever profit still be found
out of that industry and then finally
giving power this is maybe not big names
would be doing this but it's something
that could be accomplished across the
scope of an administration people at the
EPA people at the gioi in the White
House at NASA at the National Institutes
of Science in other places as credit
climate science that's been produced by
past administrations will discredit the
scientists the people who are on the
government payroll at NASA in other
places studying receiving public funds
to study the effects of climate change
and either as some people worry actually
forcing them out of a job or sort of
more passive action just denying them
research funding denying them government
platforms in which to spread that
research on the statement side the
people surrounding Donald Trump also
know that unhelpful public statements
when it comes to the Paris agreement
when it comes to just the scientific
consensus on climate
change actively can help prop up a
misinformation campaign we heard Donald
Trump just you know on Fox News say
nobody really knows if climate change is
real that's precisely the kind of talk
that emboldened climate change deniers
and lends credibility to their websites
which as of now don't have much
institutional credit credibility and and
finally threatening to remove the u.s.
from the Paris agreement is a great way
to discredit that agreement as a whole
and to prevent a deal from taking off at
a time when it was gathering a lot of
momentum for the election so let's talk
now in more detail about that Paris
agreement Trump aside he's gonna get us
out of it the agreement has already
become international law it goes fully
into effect in 2020 what could Trump
unilaterally do I mean there is a
withdrawal process but we're not just
talking about a deal that the u.s. is
the only party to I mean this is complex
stuff right so one option that's been
talked about a lot is that you just
remove the u.s. from the Paris agreement
much like article 50 of the European
Union treaty which takes two years for
brexit to actually happen there is a
four year window at delay so Donald
Trump on day one were to remove the u.s.
from Paris agreement to basically wait
out his entire term before that became
finalized the faster alternative is to
take the 1992 Senate ratified treaty for
the UNF Triple C the sort of framework
of UN climate negotiations and just
pulled the US the u.s. out of that that
only has a one year windows so that
could be done you know after his first
year in office finally though he could
formally do nothing to those treaties
but in practice do a lot to basically
cause the u.s. to fall far short of the
pledges that made as a part of the Paris
agreement basically open new coal mines
I start emitting more a prop up offshore
drilling eliminate emissions regulations
these in the US could even keep showing
up at UN climate talks he could kind of
troll the talks by you know sending an
oil CEO or something to go there and you
know get a lot of flack from the rest of
the world but just be defiant the
climate scientists I talked to a worried
the most about that because at the end
of the day it is actions on climate
change and emissions that matter more
than words and basically blocking the
implementation of these
spirit of the law of the Paris agreement
would do the most damage in the limited
time we have left Luke China now really
getting involved in a serious manner in
climate negotiations and but potentially
as one of the main drivers of curbing
emissions and mitigating climate change
caused by humans what can we gather from
that what what does what do things look
like with China potentially taking the
lead on climate I think it's highly
likely that they will take the lead on
climate china's energy and its
environmental policies always take the
lead from chinese national security
interest that's all you've seen them
opening up coal plants and shutting them
down sometimes making aggressive claims
in the South China Sea in order to
guarantee that oil can keep being
imported to China through the Straits of
Malacca but Chinese national security
interests can also be helpful for the
planet it can cause them to close down
coal mines it can cause them to address
air pollution because the Chinese
population is increasingly concerned
about the health problems from that and
finally as the sort of de facto leader
of the g77 those industrialized
countries particularly in South and
Latin America and Africa there's a
potential for China to see the business
value in trying to sell the developing
world on the solar panels and things
that it makes and I'm not surprised to
hear people trying to tell Donald Trump
this is a 21st century technology green
technology that you can win for the
United States don't fight for 19th
century and 20 20th century coal and oil
we don't want to lose the 21st century
green energy revolution to China and
that's why Leonardo DiCaprio and others
are going to his office trying to sell
him on the business argument for climate
change and and they may be successful
that's the way this could work the one
good piece of news is that no matter
what Trump says about coal right now the
low price of natural gas makes makes
coal not a particularly attractive way
to go but that is that that is a
temporary thing and that can absolutely
change we've been speaking to luke
vargas united nations bureau chief for
talk media news Luke always great to
talk to you thank you